bourdin direct sur rmc découverte nous
présente alors c'est le dernier
challenge à la mode le bouton sur les
réseaux sociaux ça s'appelle le croque
challenge voyez le craag les chaussures
les crocs chartreuse
ap absolue on va avoir un pied fin et
délicat eh bien regardez ce qu'est ce
que vous en pensez y les progs ses
chaussures en plastique assez
disgracieux zinc on pense notamment à
l'hôpital les deux versets de petits
trous elles sont assez laide et bien le
meilleur atout du chalenge consiste
attention à remplir cette chose lots de
mousse à raser avant de mettre
énergiquement son pied dedans
résultat des jets de mousse à raser un
qui sortent de la chaussure de bien
belles images au ralenti
ils font fureur sur les réseaux sociaux
vous allez me dire c'est stupide et
ridicule c'est vrai mais pour une fois
ce n'est pas dangereux à la personne si
ce n'est à la planète avec un peu de
gaspillage mais bon ça fait fureur la
mousse à raser dans les crops jeunesse
vous amuser à la maison avec vos enfants
alors ridicule avec lolo et on s'amuse
avec les enfants évidemment les deux ont
voulu le faire vous a préparé des petits
crocs alors j'aimerais évidemment que
vous fassiez ça bien on le mettra bien
évidemment sur nos réseaux sociaux et on
verra lequel des deux a le plus de like
et le plus de crocs challenge réussi et
et de fip and white magic ilm opposé tu
me dois aller à lettres leur team damien
par la fin car nous les ferons ça
devient déjà un bon 46 et un petit
apprend turine 3 un petit 40 mais
attendez ça veut rien dire on va écouter
alors attention on y va lecroq challenge
hashtag sécu des lt c'est parti vous
avez des pieds magnifique les garçons
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
thibault il est sublime j'ai envie de
dire que sur ce coup là franchement
medel le roi des crocs
[Applaudissements]